but it's plenty of stuff that we didn't
get to yesterday
youtube news oh mike did i see the
youtube news
of course i saw the youtube news can we
talk about the youtube news
everybody this isn't a right wing or
left-wing everybody on youtube
i saw jay hunter from osw was tweeting
about it too
everybody's tweeting about this what
does it matter if you hate everybody on
youtube what do you like about youtube
or you're [ __ ] beefing with everybody
this is some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] so do
you guys remember
like two two years ago when they started
doing the first wave
of demonetizations and we told you guys
on this show
that this was never about trump it's not
about politics
this has always been
[Music]
how they can figure out a way to simply
not pay you like how can we make money
but not pay everybody and uh well
turns out youtube has now figured out a
way to
not pay anybody but still monetize
videos
that's great i've received problems i'm
sure you have to probably 500 different
emails of this just this
email over and over again i tweeted it
the moment i got it last night like i
went home it was the first email i saw
and i immediately tweeted it out i was
like oh this is infuriating you're
receiving this email because we're
updating the youtube terms of service
terms to clarify our terms are provided
are
our terms and provide transparency to
our users these changes
shouldn't significantly alter your
access to youtube or your service a
summary of changes read the first one
facial recognition restrictions the
terms of service already states that you
cannot collect any information that
might identify a person without their
permission
while this has always included facial
recognition information the new terms
make that explicitly clear
the second one and don't even pay
attention to this one okay
don't youtube's right to monetize
youtube has the right to monetize all
content on the platform and ads may
appear on videos from channels
not in the youtube partner program so
can i
translate this yes please so
on top of the fact that youtube can
remove you from the partner program and
just refuse to pay you
the money they owe you um youtube has
now decided they've now reserved the
right
to make content off make money rather
off of content
that they've deemed too offensive for
you to make money off of correct
that's that's what the and again two
years ago
i [ __ ] told you this was the plan i
told you this was the [ __ ] plan
it was like they're just it's just it's
all of us
based right wingers they're kind of like
they're coming after you now
but they're going to go after other
people eventually because this has
always been
how can we run ads but find a like
a clause or some kind of toss rule
where we don't have to pay you i said
two years ago
imagine if you owned a business and you
figured out a way
to legally get the people who work for
you to keep making products in a factory
but legally not pay them you know what i
call any boss in the world
in china but any any boss in the world
whether you think they're your buddy or
not would if they were in a board room
of course how can we legally not pay
these oh yeah of course they'd be in
there going oh yeah i'll figure out a
way
so youtube has now essentially said look
your content
which is way too offensive you've had
multiple terms of service violations
we'd barely even want you on this
platform uh we cannot
in good conscience run at because
remember their excuse was
where advertisers don't want to
advertise on this sort of content that's
correct it's disgusting
why would ford motor company want to
[ __ ]
run an ad on some [ __ ] right-wing
neo-nazis uh video
well guess what now they're still going
to run ford commercials on it
and they're just going to keep 100 on
the money so this this is a huge change
in policy
um we applied for we were demonetized
when the vox
adpocalypse thing happened um we were
never re-monetized but i applied for
remonetization
last year in july i so did night waves
still long
a year more than a year and it's on hold
it's just he's just sitting there in
limbo
um so here's the question i have
if they could do this which they could
do this how does this
incentivize them to add anybody to the
partner program except for people that
they they want you know like if you
could run ads anyway on people that are
not on the partner program and i get it
private company man i understand that
but now that means why monetize anybody
right i mean what's what what would they
benefit
and cause they're gonna run ads anyway
right trust me dude
a lot of people are panicking right now
a lot of people that are
still monetized right now are going um
like you just said basically wait a
minute so
so you just have no incentive right now
to keep me in the partner program
there's no incentive no there really
isn't
especially if your content is i mean
would you consider borderline
content with whatever would they
consider borderline content or anything
like that
uh and that's not us we're not look we
haven't monetized on youtube in a very
long time so it has nothing
to do with us google google is literally
doing the deal with the thing where
they're like
look we're gonna go okay we got the
drugs they got the money
hear me out on this we're gonna go then
i'm gonna kill
everybody and i'm gonna keep the money
and the drugs like
google has now become the crooked
the backstabbing friend in the 80s
cocaine like [ __ ] crime movie
the one that's like we'll just kill
everyone and take everything
yeah that's a really good point and you
know muster tigers does anyone have a
billion dollars to start a better
platform
it's start your own youtube bro hey bro
start your own server farm
well hey you know what at least at least
we're finally breaking up big tech right
huh finally got you know we got the
senate
we got the white house we got all that
we're gonna we're gonna trust the plan
we're gonna do some plan trusting royce
we're gonna break up big tech no um
that's not what's happening no it's not
at all what's happening and then the
last thing royalty and payments and
taxes only for creators entitled to
revenue payments
such as payments we will be treated as
royalties from the u.s tax perspective
and google with whole taxes we're
required by law school
this doesn't matter with holding taxes
that part doesn't matter to me i i don't
care about that no no no no no no no no
know you want to read the book but but
but that middle part is that's the most
sinister [ __ ] i've ever seen
so i but it just kills me like this the
very
the very thing that they they deemed was
too offensive to run ads on they're now
going to run ads and keep a hundred
percent of them oh yeah
i'm i'm like i i'm the one who said this
was gonna happen and i'm still
flabbergasted
like you know what i mean it's like when
you go uh it's like when you go um
when somebody goes wow dude did you see
the tv right now your jets are up by
seven and i'll go
they're gonna [ __ ] lose it today you
know what i mean still by the end of the
game when they're losing it you go god
damn it like
i don't want to be right about this
so yeah so i mean i guess what that mean
now let's see what they do
i would be interested if anybody
watching um that's watching on you know
not not watching on you
i know ad block works and all that stuff
because anyone not watching this show
where other shows that we know are not
monetized whether they start running ads
anyway because if you're not in the
partner program
and like you said before the reason they
say that you're not allowed is because
advertisers aren't going to want to run
stuff because your content is not
advertiser friendly
but you know what else that means that
means people that have like
new up and comers from youtube to get
like a hundred you know get like a
100 views a video there's gonna be ads
on those too it's going to be
filled filled with ads
huge filled with ads um well that's
probably one of the reasons they did
this is because
i've been saying for a while um that if
you're if you're annoyed
at the sheer volume of ads you're
getting now when you go watch a
five-minute video and it has three ads
and you're like why is it like this that
was part of partly because
they got rid of the partner program and
they kicked a bunch of people out
when you have thousands of less channels
and videos that you can run ads on and
distribute ads to
but you've already sold the ads like you
still have to deliver those ads
so they're going to shove those ads down
your throat one way or another so
if you're placing ads on half of the
amount of videos you used to do
you're going to get twice as many ads
that's just the way it is so
it's been a matter of time that they
were going to figure out some workaround
to reduce the amount of [ __ ]
commercials you're seeing on the other
videos and they were like what if we
just keep the money
it's so [ __ ] up dude yeah
and um it's going to affect everybody
it's going to a big content creator
small content creators because
you know there's some people that there
are there are some people that have
purposely
would qualify for the partner program
and have decided that they
are not going to be like they've decided
like
i'm just not going to do it i'd rather
not be monetized because i don't want to
give youtube money i'm just going to be
doing my
like stick sex hammer for example is one
that just couldn't be monetized but you
decided i'm not going to be able to
i don't think he's ever been monetized
now he said i'm not going to do it i
won't do it
so there's going to be a lot of people
now that
um are
are purposely saying we're not going to
they're going to run ads anyway so
you're going to
and of course most people most normal
people
uh viewers and all aren't going to see
or know that this is a new rule you know
what i mean they're not going to know
that this is a new rule
so then now they're going to start
yelling at these content creators going
dude why there's so many ads between
your videos
and there's going to be a lot of content
creators are gonna go look i'm not the
one doing it
youtube is the one doing it so they're
gonna run and i get it i know i know
it's a private company man man it's a
private company dude
i know that's gonna be the uh yeah but
what happens when your private companies
are merging with the government
yeah you know then what yeah
i mean private companies cool and all
when you're talking about small
businesses
here's the thing about the private
company thing because i'm sick of
hearing this [ __ ] argument
yeah private company argument's great
and all when we live in an
actual free market system but we don't
we live in a system in which the market
is rigged in favor
of the big corporations uh the
government
works very hard to make sure companies
like google stay at the top
right um they do everything they can to
crush competition
to crush innovation they they do
everything they can
to undermine the free market so you
can't say a private company dude
while your private company is
undermining the very fabric of this
country
that's i'm tired of this get that
[ __ ] argument out of my face
i'm tired of hearing it's a private
company bro it's like come on man
yeah um and uh now they're gonna be
monitored i mean it's it's the same
it's the same thing that um
that twitter started doing when you go
to somebody's page now they just have
ads on your page too you know which i
mean i get it they can do whatever they
want
but at some point
when they're when there's no competition
right
when there's no competition when there's
when there's nothing else to
to go to what do you do and and i mean i
don't think
i don't think you know these start your
own
start your own [ __ ] start your own
youtube is going to be a solution
like it's not realistic remember
something and you know
we've talked about it a lot but a lot of
people don't know this like
youtube functions at a loss
you know they they don't make money for
google
they lose money for google which is
probably another reason they're doing
this or trying to find a way to add more
revenue ad revenue
you know because at the end of all this
even when this happens
are people really going to leave youtube
i know people say well i'll go to [ __ ]
well [ __ ] it doesn't have a live stream
you think but there's people that make
videos fine
you go to bit shoot where are you going
to go d live you go to d live d live has
a live stream you think but
even if you're verified they only keep
your videos up for 30 days
yeah there's no archiving and even if
there was
their their entire user interface is a
mess
you know what i mean like d live even if
you said right now d live if they
announced today
all right we're going to start saving
all of your videos would anybody really
want to scroll through d live's
interface to look for an old episode
like
it's a mess so youtube's got everyone by
the dick
everyone by the deck and there's nothing
we can do about it
and anytime somebody suggests something
be done about it you got to hear from
the libertarian retards and we're like
oh bro it's a private company
oh not aggression principle dude oh
excuse me
private ownership did private property
and it's like okay
but when your private property is now
spreading like a cancer
and is literally gonna strangle this
country to death
i stopped giving a [ __ ] about your
private pro like again
it's it's nice to have these little
principles that we stand by oh
private business private property rights
but we're not talking about a [ __ ]
pizzeria down the street right that's
getting shut down by the government
because they won't you know
uh because they want to be able to open
their business and they're getting fined
every day because of masks and [ __ ]
we're talking about a company
that has billions of dollars invested in
lobbying and influencing and donating to
[ __ ]
to all these different like once you get
to that
level we do need to have a talk about
why you have as much money as you do and
why you're as big as you do
i'm sorry that is a conversation we need
to have we need to have it
before uh companies like this take the
[ __ ] country over
we shouldn't be waiting until [ __ ]
six months after they take the country
over
and they've activated their [ __ ]
skynet robots and we're supposed to go
oh man we should maybe start having a
conversation about google
you know it's a private company yeah but
here's my
that private company thing the problem
is is that mom and pop's
[ __ ] store for example mom and pop's
general store
doesn't get doesn't have the entire us
government behind them
doesn't get special exemptions from the
u.s government and you know what mom and
pop's thrift store
isn't [ __ ] um isn't deciding
elections in this country you know what
i mean
isn't telling you the news that you
could look at uh
isn't immune to being uh isn't immune to
lawsuits like the way google and twitter
and facebook and all these companies are
you know
they get all of these exceptions you
know
so um yeah i don't um
look and the thing is people go why are
we still here because
where do you go and i know and i say
this with sincerity
what are your options um we're on we are
also streaming on d
live obviously you know we're on twitch
we don't even plug that because twitch
is probably more hardcore about banning
people than even youtube is
i just caught my second band in six
weeks
second band and it's 14 days and if i
get one more band on twitch i'm
nuked so yeah it's not twitch is
probably the worst one
of the three i think you i think
youtube would be as bad as twitch
if youtube was still as small as twitch
like if youtube didn't have as much [ __ ]
to keep an eye out for
right they'd probably be like youtube
you can kind of float under the radar a
little bit if you're not being aggre
uh egregious because it's such a big
platform and they have so much [ __ ]
they're running around chasing
um but d live it's d live's the one but
now we have the splc is going after d
live so what next
and look and and i and it's a good
question and it's a fair question you
know it's um
why are you why are we still here why
are we still using youtube
because if you want to reach more p
this is it's it's that weird catch 22
right
and and correct me if i'm i'm wrong here
but
you have to reach as many people as you
can to tell them how shitty youtube is
for example
you have to use youtube you know what i
mean that's the way it works
yeah you could sit there and you could
yell into the void for a lot of stuff
you know and you know maybe i i foresee
one day we're gonna be kicked off of
youtube i know it's probably coming i'm
not
i'm not stupid i'm not gonna be shocked
when it happens
but up until then you keep using the
platform right
um what do you do you know
how do you compete everybody that's ever
tried to compete with youtube
immediately falls apart and they get
squashed and they can't handle it
and they just can't because they don't
have [ __ ] google backing them
you know which which helps
uh [ __ ] sick of this website though
no hey man so am i so am i
but what do you again what do you do
what do you do you know i mean
d live only there's some people that are
doing that and the people that are doing
d live only aren't doing it by choice
you know no of course they're doing it
because they were kicked off on youtube
yeah because everybody that does d live
that has the option
they're still using those other
platforms
i mean even baked alaska when they went
on that [ __ ] rv thing
he had his d live but the only time he
was only on d
live was when he would get zapped
because he had i think he got like
three or four accounts [ __ ] zapped
during that trip
and every once in a while he'd be back
on d live but even even on that rv trip
like people were like all right i got to
make a new youtube i got to get back up
on youtube everybody knows you got to be
it sucks but you got to be on youtube if
you want to reach anybody